halle nach vier jahren anschauen wenig
überraschend haben die anderen
sogenannten demokratischen fraktionen
unseren kandidaten für das amt des
vize-präsidenten
nicht mitgewählt obwohl es
demokratischer usus ist dass alle
fraktionen eine vertretung
haben und dementsprechend
halten wir natürlich an herrn professor
kaufmann fest der im übrigen ja auch
früher im thüringischen landtag
landtags vizepräsident gewesen ist wir
wollen festhalten dass wir
absolut verärgert sind über die
standards die hier im deutschen
bundestag durch die anderen fraktionen
gesetzt werden hier werden um es
festzuhalten
hier wird nicht nur eine fraktion die
alternative für deutschland im deutschen
bundestag ausgegrenzt wir werden
millionen von wählern ausgegrenzt die
uns gewählt haben und die wir im
deutschen bundestag
vertreten das sollte man nie vergessen
ich übergebe das fortan professor
kaufmann ja ich bin aktuell noch
vizepräsident des thüringer landtags sie
dürfen mich also ruhig mit vizepräsident
ansprechen der bundestag hatte heute
einen demokratie test zu bestehen den
osten demokratietest der
legislaturperiode und er ist krachend
durchgefallen sind offenbar eine es ist
eine mehrheit der abgeordneten weiter
auf dem weg hier spaltung zu
voranzutreiben und auszugrenzen das
widerspricht völlig dem was heute die
bundestagspräsidentin in ihrer rede
gesagt hat dass das
parlament ein inklusiver ort sei an dem
alle ihre meinung kundtun dürfen und
gleichberechtigt mit tun dürfen das ist
offenbar nicht der fall es ist schade
aber wir müssen damit leben zurzeit
vielen herzlichen dank bis zum nächsten
mal danke